if you earn much more with less work
is that of course 1 good good way
is 2 and 1 / 2 to 2 and 1 / 2
so you work 2 and 1 / 2 days
and it is spoken for 2 and 1 / 2 tons
for her yes then you can't complain
1 bit crazy about salaries no Maaike here
I can't complain either
but old minister I don't hear it
she feels some relief
when you watch that press conference
that you don't have to do it anymore
well no you feel more
that you can feel it all the way back how it is
if you wear thatverantwoordelijkheid anyway
and like Erik van Den Burg
he puts his whole soul and bliss into it
that really weighs on you
and that does something to you when you are in such a position
that should also be
but that also makes it difficult
yes but I really don't ask what in general
but what you think
when you see it Are you glad you're gone
well there are days when I don't miss it
let me put it this way
yes that is very bad
if you earn much more with less work
is of course 1 good good way for everyone
what she deserves now
well I think I'm just making that
not so many hours anymore and it is precise
the 2 and 1 / 2 to 2 and 1 / 2
so you work 2 and 1 / 2 days
and there is talk for 2 and 1 / 2 tons for her
yes then you can't cum about salaries
no Maaike here
I can't complain either,
but I thought so too
nope
and I work
than
I remember that moment when the VVD ran away from the room
when there was 1 minimum
salary increase for nursing
had to be asked
and now madam goes
because she can make more money from the room
yes that is my Father
and the nonsense this completely you want
I the cabinet had been outgoing for a long time
it was said that it would take another 3 weeks
before there would be 1 new cabinet
I thought I was doing well
to make sure I had 1 other job
and that you would not end up in redundancy pay for long
because there was really talk at the time
that the cabinet was almost ready
Used for a good cause for 4 years
27 years continuously
had politically responsible positions
so I think this is really nonsense
I really took myverantwoordelijkheid